hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i have a technical topic
for you uh that's about how digital
audio is transmitted
and
audiophile concerns around
jitter and noise
the motivation for the uh uh
presentation came from people asking me
about it but also this uh um
uh video from darko audio a youtuber
that covers audio
and
the meat of the
topics actually after the introduction
but the introduction starts with him
holding up these two bottles of water
saying that it's silly to ask for
measurements of those uh when he could
just open the bottle and and taste them
and therefore what he's about to present
uh which i'll talk about in a second
should not trigger anybody asking for
measurements
and uh
he goes on and says you know it would be
very silly for somebody to go and demand
that measurements be provided for
bottles of water
and
proceeds to taste them and i think he
naturally says that fancier water is is
better than the supermarket water
it's a mistake uh in in what he's
claiming in that uh we don't ask for
measurements uh we'd love to see uh
tasting uh
and listening tests uh
in his case all he's got to do is taste
the two bottles of water blind not
knowing which is which
and then telling us which one's better
we'd love that kind of subjective
control testing far more than
measurements i don't even know what to
do with
measurements of water
but i do know that a lot of research is
done in in food and and tasting are done
frequently blind or major uh cooking
shows where the tasting is is done blind
so
i think his analogy is quite misplaced
uh go ahead and have somebody else pour
each bottle of water into two identical
glasses and
let's have him test that multiple times
and then
we can tell
that his opinion is is not biased
towards price and and looks and branding
and so forth
and uh
the meat of this presentation as i said
comes later in that this is a review of
of this streamer forget what the brand
is at the bottom is a few thousand
dollar digital audio streamer meaning
that it it can book local content from
your network or from the cloud
and then feeds it to a dac and then you
can listen to it and he's got a stack of
them in here as you can see is the
largest one that i think inuit was the
one that it was testing down here i
think this is uh
uh not a sona so who's their competitor
it'll come to me
and he goes up this is zone is over here
and then he's got uh an allo uh one over
here and and then some other uh embedded
one and uh sadly and naturally he says
the the biggest and most expensive one
sounds the best and then
you know progressively as the thing is
smaller and cheaper the sound degrades
um and then he confesses very quickly
that you know this is incredulous you
know to say that
you know these digital sources have
different sounds when the the source of
the content is identical and he then
goes on to explain that um what is
actually transmitted as digital audio is
actually analog and therefore he's got
all the problems of analog
and specifically has jitter
in there so
and he goes in and you know he's got a
fancy production crew and they overlay
graphics and say well this is what you
think a digital audio looks like but in
reality doesn't look like this
and he's very correct about that i'm
going to talk about this
in a second
so
is digital audio transmission analog the
quick answer is absolutely yes and you
know it doesn't have to be digital audio
it can be digital anything inside your
computer there are tons of
data streams that are running around and
the waveform can indeed be distorted
but what
distinguishes digital transmission from
analog in is that we actually don't care
about the uh the the small or even
medium level changes in in the signal
itself we set a threshold if look at the
waveform on the right we set a threshold
in here we said look anything above this
threshold is a one anything below this
threshold is a zero so i don't care that
the waveform has been distorted over
here i'm easily able to extract a one
and a zero and one's over here and
indeed these signals can degrade very
close to this line and all is well
now once it gets really really bad and
we flatline on the threshold then hell
breaks loose but until that point you
know the beauty of digital is that it
can take an analog
concept
with variations and convert it into
something that's got exceptional noise
immunity
and this is what makes it powerful and
the fact that we can ignore noise and
variation uh
completely sort of counters to what what
he's assuming and what he's talking
about so just because something is
analog doesn't mean that that is bad yes
if we treat this as an analog voltage
with all these variations that would be
bad that's why analog
has noise in it but when we treat this
digital
that is not the case at all so on at a
fundamental level there's a truism in
what he's saying but he's completely
bastardizing this into something and
it's not now
i could stop here and say this is
completely wrong and i can get 100
digital engineers that
sit next to me and just laugh at what is
presented but i want to be fair there
are issues in here that go beyond the
superficial treatment and dismissal so
let's uh go into that
now
this pretty graph that i showed you it
only
happens if i let's say i've got digital
audio over very short distances instead
of short distance let's say i have a
broadcast stadium oops
broadcast studio and and i've got
signals have been transmitted between
rooms and even buildings and now we're
talking hundreds of feet and across
hundreds of feet these voltages uh
come down in value we get losses we get
filtering these edges become less sharp
and indeed
damage can be done it's very seriously
to to this way from to a point where it
doesn't do it doesn't transmit digital
data and
good news is that when that happens that
the impact is catastrophic in analog you
know if you keep increasing noise it
just gets noisier and noisier noisier
digital doesn't work like that has this
cliff where that the
transmission is perfect to all of a
sudden we can't capture something and it
could be one bit or it could be a
thousand billion sequence that get
corrupted and when that happens is very
catastrophic in case of video all sudden
you see pixels that are gone and and
corrupted uh you probably have seen this
especially if you have an antenna for
digital uh
video
dtv standards and for audio uh most
people assume they know what this look
sounds like but they don't and i've
produced some
samples of data loss over uh uh usb for
uh that's transmitting audio and i can
assure you the sound degrades
substantially
there's glitches there's buzzing there's
pops there's discontinuity
it is not at all
the subtle thing where
micro details change and the timing has
changed bass is a little softer the data
transmission has no notion of what that
data looks like or what it is for it's
just a bit and if you obliterate one or
more bits the data samples can vary
sharply from one another and that's what
causes the ticks and pops and glitches
there is no such thing as a subtle
degradation now to make that data loss
happen over usb i had to create a 30
foot cable with with 15 foot extensions
a very very thin usb cable with a lousy
transmitter and receiver
to cause it to have data loss and in a
good connection actually still couldn't
get it to fail
and indeed if you have a
dac that's hooked up or you that's over
your spitf coax or or
usb and it's any reasonably short length
of
cabling there is no data loss whatsoever
just put that out of your vocabulary
data loss can happen if you exceed the
standards and
that means going many many meters so if
you're going from one room to another
room
or upstairs downstairs yes you can get
data loss but in any kind of stereo
setup where you got a stereo system
sitting someplace and you got your
streamer here and next to it there's a
a dac that's five or six or eight or ten
feet of cabling it absolutely will not
have any data errors so assume 100 that
there's no data errors and if there is
no there's glitches and pops and it's
not some subtle staging or micro
dynamics or any other silly subjectivist
commentary
now so far i've only covered one aspect
of of digital audio which is what the
data samples are he says this is the pcm
value of this and the dac will take that
pcm value and convert it to an analog
value and it just follows whatever the
digital stream
uh
is but we also need to tell the dac
how fast
the bits are coming what is basically
the effective sample rate of the data is
because we can have 44.1 48 96 from what
have you
and the dac needs to know that to be
able to play it at the right timing if
it plays at the wrong time that can
generate
distortion
um the
most classic links that we have is coax
and tossling both of them are called
spdif and then there's a aes ebu
professional standard that's a balance
and whenever using these connections uh
key thing to understand technically is
that the host is a master so if it's a
streamer or as a cd player or a computer
that's playing the host is telling the
dac i'm going to send you the split
stream and you better follow the spit
streams and only output your samples
whenever i give them to you you might
think well i'm playing 44.1 can i just
tell the dac that it should play at 44.1
the answer is no that's a nominal rate
for it to display on its display but the
dac is not allowed onto on his own to
assume there's a fixed data rate the
host can actually change this by up to
five percent it can speed up and slow
down even at displaying and uh the dac
needs to stay in sync with it this is
called a master slave kind of
relationship and the dac is the slave
this is a very poor architecture
it was done for simplicity
and the problem with now with this
scheme is that the dac has now has to
extract a timing of how fast the bits
are coming at it and convert that to a
sample rate internally and unfortunately
with coax or any of these links there's
only a
two
wires going there a shield and a center
data pin there isn't a separate clock
pin that says hey here's the sample rate
that's coming at you and just take this
the data itself has pulses and these
pulses need to be
grabbed and the distance between the
pulses is what tells the attack what the
sample rate is and
the second thing that can happen is that
there can be noise on this line and that
noise can actually be coupled from the
host all the way out to the uh target
toslink being an optical link helps a
lot with this uh oftentimes people have
ground loops and you go when they have a
coax connection or usb connection and
they switch to toslink and that goes
away so this can be a problem and so the
architecture here is limited and it can
have problems um
so let's look at this thing with with
real uh
detail and instrumentation i took my
audio precision
analyzer which has both the spdif output
and input and
i uh had it generate this bit of signal
and then i took that and hooked it up to
my uh
oscilloscope tektronix oscilloscope and
had it gen display what is called an eye
pattern
so if you follow my cursor so every bit
sort of looks like this is nothing is
basically negative meaning it's a zero
and then it gradually goes up and then
stays constant here then it comes down
so you're seeing one bit what is
overlaid on it is another bit that has
arrived and it's out of cycle with it uh
this is a digital scope so it's able to
catch these things and if you let it run
often enough where a lot of bits get
overlaid on top of each other
you get what is called an eye pattern
it's called an eye pattern because these
things look like two eyes if you look at
the left and right eyes
and engineers talk about the clear eye
in that if this area in the middle is
very clear and very wide
the receiver has no trouble extracting
the data
from this link and indeed that's the
case in here
even though i have a cable is three to
five feet between the audio precision
and tektronix scope we can see the eye
patterns is extremely clear but we also
see that as darko has said is that
there's no this is not digital uh the
waveform the waveform actually has a
slope to it and gradually goes up to one
and
the uh dac actually grabs this uh
zero crossing over here as the timing
point of view so it says okay
start a clock here
okay the next one came over here and
these two points are now the the
distance between them and measured in
time is now your sample or bit rate
that's coming at the dac
if you take this waveform now and uh
jiggle it left and right what we call
jitter
or make it noisy where the edges are
fluttering over here this timing
measurement can get uh
changed as well you can have random
errors in here or it can have um
a deterministic so let's say the
waveform jumps once a second left and
right while they'll also transmit to the
deck
now
good news is that the decks have been
designed to actually work in a far more
hostile environment all the way up to
what the spec requires so you you know
you could have 1500 feet of coil cable
so they have an internal flywheel
mechanism if you know how turntables use
the momentum of the platter to get a
steady speed they have their own
waveform called pll or phase lock loop
and the phase lock loop uh it basically
measures these this timing and generates
an internal clock that's immune to high
frequency changes low frequency can
still get through but high frequency one
it just filters them out and doesn't
care so if there's very high frequency
noise in here let's say from your cell
phone or wi-fi or you know am station fm
station everything it it
happily filters all that and gets a
clean one and we can see in here the
waveform is very clean anyway this is an
actual waveform this is not a made up
thing and the scope is receiving and
displaying it and we can see that we
have no trouble over here and these
edges in here are quite precise so we
don't need that but if we do need it um
the mechanism is inside your dac and
that's why when you go change one
digital cable to another digital cable
you know you don't notice anything
because while the filtering is there and
the fidelity of the signal is already
quite high
usb audio
started off using a similar kind of uh
mechanism the people designed the usb
audio initially and the audio devices
worked the same way in that the uh the
pc was the master and the dak was a
slave that actually caused worse jitter
than than
than spdif because you know it's a
computer and the computer just you know
doesn't care if that timing so precise
as first usb pack is coming in but after
a few years of usb audio being out there
um some clever folks came up with a
mechanism to
conv use a asynchronous mode of usb
where the usb is still actually trying
to transmit real-time audio stream but
the
the dac picks its own clock so this time
he says hey i'm playing 44.1
and
i'm going to tell the host if it's five
percent faster i'm going to say hey slow
down slow and slow down until it slows
down the four four to forty four point
one and if if it's going too slow i can
actually tell to speed up so you know
it's like you as being in charge of a um
uh you know autopilot you know you're
basically accelerating decelerating uh
cruise control in your car and
that's what this is a mechanism where
because usb products are smart they have
memory and they can have a cushion
against the host not being in sync with
it
is able to basically eliminate any
dependency whatsoever on a digital clock
in a in a usb so usb is also serial link
it does have a separate clock but its
clock could also have all the noise
issues that i've talked about but that
clock on usb is only used to extract the
data uh once the data is extracted it's
never used for timing the timing the the
dac is the master and you can have a
very high precision high quality clock
that's right next to the dac chip
doesn't care at all about like speed of
trying to measure those corners and and
arrive at
good timing
okay
so in case of usb we don't worry about
data errors and we don't worry about
jitter over usb bus it simply is not
something that's in the vocabulary that
we have
so do we say that the bits are bits is a
common objectivist thing to say and
laugh at anybody who says you know
digital audio can degrade performance
the answer is no you can't say that
because i've talked already about noise
and jitter and let's talk a little bit
about more about noise a usb cable
has data and glock but it also has power
and it also has a ground
some dags run on that usb power i had to
shut
modi ii
that any noise on a five volt supply
would translate into hideous jitter on
its analog output
and
you could take that back and plug it
into five different computers you get
five different measurements and
fortunately that's an example of
something that just shouldn't have ever
gotten out and even at that time there
were a ton of other decks that didn't
have this problem and today the quality
of usb receivers or anything i test and
recommend is just superb on this front
although occasionally i still run into
this in some avr's i see this thing some
you know smart amplifiers i've found
that their usb receivers are not robust
and that can pick up noise through
either uh
ground or or voltage um
the uh
excuse me
one of the common symptoms a lot of
people report for example is that with
an internal dac to a computer or even a
crappy dac externally
when their computer gets busy they
actually they can actually hear the
activities especially when the gpu the
graphics process and inside the computer
starts to get going they can hear
you know different kinds of noises all
the way through their audio device so
that proves that bits are not bits
because remember the data hasn't changed
so that from that point of view is the
same but because we have an electrical
link that electrical link ultimately can
transmit stuff there's a you can have a
galvanic isolator that you can buy
either separately or one that's in in
some dax that really provides complete
isolation between the two uh fortunately
if you get a good deck 99.99 of time
it's not a problem and if he is balanced
audio output as i always recommend that
actually becomes quite immune to this
problem it's only
mainly an issue when you have rca
connections on your deck
okay
now does this mean we don't get jitter
noise actually we get plenty of it and i
measure it all the time this legit the
main source of jitter and noise isn't
the lane the link or the host behind it
it's actually internally generated
a dac is a mixed signal device it has
both digital and analog subsystems and a
lot of times the noise inside its own
digital section can bleed into the
analog or you could have lousy power
supply that has noise on it all of that
gets translated to an analog output of
the dac reason is that audio dacs have
extremely high resolution the bit depth
even a crappy one say 16 bit cd audio we
can go the way up 24 bits so even
slightly you know movement in those
samples generates error so from that
point of view it requires a very very
clean implementation fortunately we get
that
in a lot of devices now what i've
highlighted in here is that to know that
if we have a problem here we measure we
can measure jitter we can measure noise
all the things that
darko says well you know we can't
measure we should measure it's like no
if you're going to talk about something
technical being a problem and you name
it as jitter well we have tools that let
us measure jitter so here's an example
of a topping dm7 and a channel deck that
i measured and this graph is just from
the review itself and
i feed a special signal to it it's
called the j test
and uh we can see that the noise floor
down here this in the analysis i can
bring this noise floor down and able to
even resolve these spikes in here there
this is a valid set of bits that's a
single bit toggling at the limits of 24
bits so we're able to actually correctly
see
the sequence of bits in here being
resolved and if you look at the spectrum
in here just absolutely clean all we see
just randomness of noise at extremely
low levels so it's an example of a case
where this is running from my computer
which is a noisy source and a noisy
streamer and it's wailing with 16 cores
in it and gpu and everything else yet
this stack absolutely does not care and
it's producing exceptionally clean
signal resolving it down to 24 bits of
resolution
but it's not always that way as i
mentioned this you know these things can
degrade and here's an on qr tx rz50 that
i tested i think a year ago
and uh we can actually a few months ago
uh 212. and
we see that not only does it have all
these spikes this is identical
measurement so it should be just like
the other one with noise down here and
just a few bits down here but instead we
get this regular pattern this regular
pattern is actually part of the
j test signal and is bleeding from the
digital section that's receiving that
data
into the analog section so remember all
these measurements are actually
measuring what comes out of the deck i'm
not actually measuring this clock to see
how accurate it is i don't care it's a
black box i just say give me your
waveform and the waveform should only
have this one spike in it at 12 kilos
anything else is
unacceptable so all of a sudden we see
an excessive uh
pattern over here over coax
over hdmi uh is much cleaner but it's
noise floor still way up here much worse
than what i just showed you
but you still notice this comment in
here as bad as this is with the eye
being insulted that there's all this in
here compared to the other that i look
at these measurements and i say look the
threshold of hearing is around -115 so
almost all of these things are below
threshold of hearing the few of them
over here above threshold of hearing but
they're right next to a very strong 12
kilohertz tone and therefore masking
will make sure that you don't hear that
and on top of that real content doesn't
have full ample to 12 kilohertz anyway
usually so
as bad as this is you're not gonna hear
jitter from this uh avr you know it
technically is poorly engineered you
shouldn't have this but the fact that it
does is still not a bothersome thing now
there's an automatic assumption that the
better the story and higher the price
and the fancier the brand the cleaner
these things must be uh it's not so i've
tested a lot of products indeed
unfortunately many high-end products
have inverted performance where the
price goes up but performance also goes
down and how do we know that we measure
it so this is a twenty five hundred
dollar deck um this is an audio gd
master at seven uh china chinese dac
that is revered used to be so it's a
massive box with tons of over design
circuits in there but look at this
jitter performance usb's down here is
still not as clean as what i showed you
in topping it does have some jitter
components but again they're at minus
130 db or so when i switch to coax and
toslink all of a sudden the problem gets
far worse remember now it has to go
extract the clock itself and when he's
trying to do that it just has a is doing
a very poor job in here and
is it going to be audible no this
threshold of hearing is way up here and
just shows poor engineering it's like if
you can have clean
jitter and noise why not get that and
and put up with this thing and now you
wouldn't pay twenty five hundred dollars
and still got boars performance
um this is a recent example that i
tested this name unity atom uh this is
coax input and look at the noise floor
up here is way elevator in here which
means got random noise that can cause
jitter it's one of the things but one of
the other thing it does is that it masks
all the jitter components below this so
these you know if the noise floor was
down here we would see a very horrible
looking picture with all these spikes
being jitter components over here and
right now they look like they're small
but in reality they're way above
a good noise floor of another system
clearly this is not
something that you want to be proud of
you paid a lot of money for this dac i
forget how much it is it's thousands of
dollars and and
you know look at the noise floor that
you get so more money didn't get you
less noise and less jitter
another example 7 500
uh
sacd player a cdsa cd player from rans
sa-10 and look at these pronounced
spikes in here these are all digital
activities inside the uh
the unit they're bleeding into the
clock circuits or our reference voltage
of the dac resulting in this
deterministic
spikes coming out here again
i'm always fair i do a psychoacoustics
analysis real quick and i say well
threshold of hearing is at -115
so no this is not going to be audible
but by
you know you pay 7 500
big heavy cd blur but you know you're
getting far worse performance than my
computer this is my computer for driving
a dac that's just a few hundred dollars
and it's a channel that i can get this
clean
and then you go get a
you know 7 500 transport thinking oh my
god it's going to be so much better
digital stream that it outputs it's like
no that it's not very clean
um
let's talk about uh
streamer back to the you know what
darker talked about i've measured the
digital stream
coming out of a lot of streamers that
have spdif output and i'll tell you the
it's just gonna become boring because
the amount of jitter they have on those
links on a short length of cable it is
so small as to not matter and uh it did
any little bit that it does have the dac
will filter it anyway i can show jitter
down to one or two picoseconds and i've
shown that but it's like one or two
picoseconds i mean it's just not
something that's in our vocabulary as
far as impact audibly now let's look at
an example of a streamer that was way on
top
that he was showing and this streamer
not only is it a streamer it's built on
raspberry pi a single board computer but
also the dac built in and the whole
thing cost 210 209
look at its performance over here look
how clean it is it's not as perfect as
what i just showed you in the topping
stand alone deck we have you know few
spikes in here it could be jitter
asparagus things but their levels are
minus 140 db in here so it's absolutely
utterly inaudible and not a concern at
all and if a 200 dollar deck and
streamer combo can produce this why
would they worry would to you know say
well is there something that's cleaner
than this
um
i i've already been explaining this to
you um every time i make this jitter
measurement i do as uh psychoacoustic
analysis as i've been showing you and
you know maybe once or twice i've seen
something that made me think oh wait you
know that could be audible in general
just shows you know poor engineering and
i said look you could have designed this
product without this
and costs nothing more i mean basically
it's just poor engineering design skills
hygiene that causes those that lack of
isolation and poor clock extraction
there's no reason to have jitter this
has been you know people have had 30 40
years of experience dealing with a
digital audio jitter um on this thing so
now even if
we do have jitter then
it means that saying that jittery cause
bad sound is not valid because you know
across
almost 400 devices that i've tested
maybe one or two of them have had bad
jetter the other ones no matter how bad
they are
they haven't risen up to the
level of audibility let alone be
something that's that's nasty
but we only know that because we measure
so if you go by
random five thousand dollar streamer
just like that moran's transport it may
actually be worse anyway so this lay
assumption that i paid more and it's
more expensive and it's a bigger box
therefore must be cleaner is wrong and
certainly wrong to just run around and
say oh our differences in sound on this
thing okay
so
translating this into streamers
basically if the streamer is outputting
a digital stream and it's got a usb
connection or even speed of connection
and you're getting a good deck that i
recommend you know which goes down to
100 bucks it's just a non-issue at all
and and performance is the same
regardless of the noise of the source a
lot of people say oh the computer's
noisy therefore dedicated streaming must
sound better no
you know every measurement that i make i
actually use my computer as a streamer
when i test streamers and
there are streamers that measure that
sign it's 120 db there's as squeaky
clean as low noise as you can possibly
get
so the it is true that the sources can
be noisier than others but it is not
true that you can just you know wet them
in the air and say oh this is noisy and
the other one therefore must be worse or
better as dark was doing there's zero
legitimate reasoning behind that we can
measure it and across all these devices
i've measured what he's doing is just
totally totally incorrect
okay so where are we
it's just not a concern somebody i get
this all the time what streamers should
i buy i said buy the one has the
features and the price and support that
you want
that's what i do you know it just makes
no difference my main system i built a
silent windows pc
and that runs the room server for me and
that is my streamer device would i do it
again
i don't know i don't like the fact that
windows update constantly reboots it and
sometimes roon doesn't start and i gotta
go manually restart it
and
uh so from that point it is not good
know that every other
streamer you buy that is not a windows
or mac pc is gonna run an operating
system called linux because of all the
networking other features you need you
need a full blown os therefore it's a
computer usually it's a multi-core
cpu
yes it's not as as high performance as a
computer is but it's not a noise-free
little you know custom circuit it's it's
a full-blown computer that's in there
and you have challenges in that you may
not get updates if that company goes out
of business how you're going to get it
to work and support new features in the
future uh nice thing about the pc or mac
is that you know it's an open platform
and forever you're in charge of that the
downside is the manageability of it so
you got to decide you know what works
for you but that is the uh important
thing the next important thing is to get
a dac that i recommend and i've
recommended i don't know probably 100
dacs and out of them 50 of them are just
amazing performance state-of-the-art um
for good measure use a balanced xlr
connection if you can build a dac and a
preamp and amplifier that all balanced
you save yourself a lot of grief with
ground noise and ground loops
on that and you do that you'll be one in
a million that you you're still gonna
get noise and what have you jitter is
just not a concern in any of those
now
i've talked about
a lot of measurements but i started the
whole presentation on on subjective
testing and i absolutely absolutely love
to see subjective testing from any
reviewer but subjective testing needs to
be blind it can't be based on price and
size and who gave you a freebie unit the
next day the previous day and what have
you if you think the sound is so easily
distinguishable from one to the other
just do the listening test blind the
digital levels likely are the same so
just have someone do an a b test for you
to repeat it a dozen times and let's see
if you get eight or ten times uh out of
12 that you guessed correctly which one
is which then it's fantastic we'll chuck
all these measurements aside and we'll
go by that shoot a video of that
document the protocol how you did that
that's great but if you're going to do a
sided test as dark goes down it's just
as worthless as a fortune cookie at the
chinese restaurant
you know it just means nothing
he's so biased by by classic folklore
out there and i can't blame him
personally because so many people are
biased to think if you pay more you get
more that's how real life works you know
you buy a hundred thousand dollar car
it's comfortable and faster than than a
used five thousand dollar car
but just know that when it comes to
audio unfortunately that equation has
been thrown out long time ago
companies are happy to sell you stuff
that's super expensive because so much
of it went into the
the channel that distributes it the
machinery the you know all this other
stuff that is not performance related
hopefully
you learned something out of this uh
presentation and you're more educated
both when you're talking to objectivists
and subjectivists because there are
people mistaken about these concepts on
both sides of the equation
okay
see in a future video bye-bye